welcome to the AI in the future of us a
podcast Style video series that explores
the ways AI is shaping our feature and
how we can prepare for the changes that
Leia had I am your host Thera seconder
and today we are joined by yasvin Ahmed
who is a managing director for the
activation and data analytics within
Google Cloud thank you for being here
today Yasmin
it's a pleasure for it
so could you share some of the AI
developments that you witnessed during
your career for us
absolutely so actually my career started
back in the uh in Hands-On on data as a
data scientist and in fact before I was
in the business world I was in the
academic world and what amazes me is
many of the
um AI algorithms that we talk about even
the large language model algorithms many
of those have existed in academic papers
for decades uh but very much so only a
few or select people could access those
algorithms because the infrastructure
the compute Etc was just not there to be
able to take advantage of these AI
algorithms so what I have seen over my
career is back in those data science
days we would dabble with deep learning
um algorithms with neural networks with
with sophisticated AI but most times we
would come back to doing just machine
learning the the standard kind of
predictive models learning so there was
a lot of dabbling but the the
infrastructure just wasn't there and
suddenly very rapidly what we've seen is
the compute infrastructures have
developed rapidly the storage Etc which
means storing accessing large volumes of
data has become cheap enough and the
compute has become accessible enough
that actually today you can take
advantage of AI not just as a data
science experiment but now in the real
world
yes you are absolutely right and taking
me myself back into my academic life as
well what you said it's I used to work
at the national sphere Computing
Services and it was so expensive right
that the super computers tens or
millions of dollars now you can get it
particularly because of the cloud as
well just you know it access to your
fingertips right and this gives us
phenomenal opportunities but one of the
keys that we are saying is that the data
governance and data governance is going
to be a central concern in particular
with the implementation of the Gen AI
across every aspects of the business a
majority of the tech Enterprise have
started to communicate different
guidelines and guard rails reflecting
the ability for employ employees to
leverage different gen AI Solutions
right and this is really driven by the
data Garden security concerns as well
and those in particular building
customer facing uh you know generic
probabilities embedded into their core
product
must take very specific steps in your
opinion what are the key data governance
considerations if you are applying llms
and gen AI within your organization or
within your applications
that's a great question for us so before
we even get into specifics of governance
and data quality and lineage Etc
fundamentally one of the strong things
I'm hearing from our customers here at
Google is
is AI secure and all of these large
language models are being hosted by
various entities across the world when I
send my data to the AI am I exposing
myself because I'm taking my data out of
a really secure data Cloud environment
and I'm sending it to an AI to an llm to
train the large language model to
execute on the large language model and
even in terms of large language model
prompts
am I sending pii information in that
prompt to an an AI llm somewhere else so
one of the core principles that also we
believe here at Google is
bring the AI to your data your data is
secure within your data Cloud you should
not be taking your data out of your data
cloud and and sending it to an AI to a
bolted on EI piece it's got to be about
bringing the AI and infusing it with
your data platform so that you are
keeping your data within that secure
perimeter that you have so whether it's
training large language models or it's
sending prompts to large language models
your data should not be exposed to the
outside world and another concern I hear
is as we're training these large
language models and EI
is the AI learning from my company's
data because my company's data is
sensitive and I don't want that being
accessible to other companies out there
so I also think fundamentally it starts
with ensuring that AI is governed itself
so the AI is sandbox so your company
data pii information never actually
leaks into the main core large language
model and so the large language model
will not learn your company's sensitive
information and then pass it on to
another company so those are a few core
principles that we're operating on it's
bring the AI to your data not your data
out of your secure parameter to the AI
and secondly sandbox large language
models so that yes you can tune and and
train them but the tuned and trained
version of the large language model is
never accessible to anyone outside your
Enterprise
and absolutely and I hear what you're
saying because when you bring your data
you know AI to your data effectively you
you still have full control of your data
you control what goes into the model as
well right and all and in Google we
follow the
key principles around we are we don't
use anyone else's data on training our
models right so and this is a key uh key
capability that we provide and and why
do you think that the data garment is so
important for successful implementation
of jnai as well with that in mind
and and here's the thing with governance
for for Gen EI it's when you're training
these models they are learning from the
data that is being passed into the model
so governance becomes super critical
because that model to be trusted to be
responsible to be reliable it's all
about the data Foundation that you feed
it and if your data Foundation is has
data that has biases encoded in it or
incorrect inaccuracies errors the model
will learn those inaccuracies or those
errors the model will learn those biases
so it's actually not the algorithms or
the models that are biased in fact I
often say you know an algorithm is just
math it's just calculations
is actually the underlying data that
often contains those biases that
contains those inaccuracies those issues
so governance really has a critical role
here in ensuring that data Foundation is
trusted that data Foundation is high
quality so do you know where the data
came from the lineage of that data can
you profile that data and understand the
quality can you assess that data and
ensure it's robust enough that you're
going to run your business and make
decisions based on an llm that's trained
on that data
yes and it's it's I think the key to uh
how human-centric approach right and
having that Humanity in in your
applications you are effectively
eliminating all the buyers around it as
well by using the right tool and write
data sets and by using the data sets
that you really trust in as well and
then with that I want to you know take
it to a slightly different approach in a
sense that data tactics and machine
learning within organizations are often
treated as two separate disciplines and
and applying the data governance across
because of that and ml governance
becomes challenging where do you see the
main challenges on on this and how can
we really improve a little bit on that
as well
that's a great question and I think it's
time to stop thinking about data machine
learning AI all of these things in silos
so in fact now when we're thinking about
our strategy and roadmaps around
governance we're talking about
governance extended from data to AI
and that incorporates not just your
structured data it's all types of data
right you need governance across your
your unstructured and your structured
data you're entire lake house but then
moving beyond the data oh and sorry it
might even include third-party data sets
but then moving beyond the data that
governance has to extend to any analytic
model that you're building whether it's
a machine learning Model A large
language model whatever kind of AI model
that you build you need governance
across the Analytics
and when we talk about analytics
governance it's ensuring that it's not
just the data that you're version
controlling and managing and watching
you actually version controlling
managing watching measuring the analytic
models because over time those analytic
models will change they will adapt you
want to continue to monitor those models
are they as effective accurate as they
were when you launched the model how do
you track that over time
also how do I do things like a b testing
with models my data science teams my
analytic teams are constantly innovating
how do I watch all of these different
models and understand which is
performing or are not so great and
critical here is for regulated
Industries for regulated Industries if
you make a decision using a machine
learning or an AI Model A year ago about
giving somebody a loan
The Regulators can come and ask you why
did you make that decision why did
person a get the loan and person B
didn't and you need to be able to
explain what those models did and
explainability is a huge issue that
we're seeing come up in the EI World
especially with things like large
language models it's not always easy to
explain why the model made the decision
it did and so really being able to
govern models Version Control understand
which version of the model was running
and be able to go back to it these are
all Concepts that are really important
and really do extend governance Beyond
to AI
yes and and that's interesting right and
it comes back into a little bit of data
and also how you apply the main
principles of building applications as
well you need to it the way that I
always say is that it is test test and
test so you need to bring your you need
to understand the data that goes in but
it's an iterative process you need to
test you need to understand a little bit
what's going on because usually the the
main organizations treat as a black box
really they don't understand what's
going on or some algorithms it's very
difficult to understand what you know
how they process the data that you have
and how they come out with the decisions
and and I hear you so and with that you
know I like to look ahead a little bit
within the AI and data analytics
ecosystem and what do you believe is the
most exciting potential for AI
application we have yet to see and in
particular with the Gen AI in in you
know in mind as well
great question and so as I think about
the future of AI and also taking into
account the governance piece today what
I hear from customers is they are making
sure there is a human in the loop so
we're working on some exciting marketing
journey I use cases but today
organizations are talking about they're
still being a human in the loop that
validates even if it's spot checking
different outputs from the large
language models so today I see those new
applications are emerging but they're
still caution there's still
um an element of being careful about how
we apply those llms but as I look into
the future those applications are just
numerous across the Enterprise and I
think as we get more sophisticated in
our AI approaches and we're more sure
about the governance around the data and
the I2 those applications are only going
to explode across the Enterprise and in
particular killer I think with Jenny I
different to other analytics
um algorithms or technology I've seen
it's not just about unlocking new use
cases and delivering business value
through a use case
to me Jenny I has the potential of
really fundamentally helping
organizations change the way they
operate
Jenny I has the promise of delivering
huge amounts of productivity efficiency
gains from your data teams who actually
will not have to spend all that time
engineering and wrangling data because
large language models can help you do
that and often do it better than a human
can and so we're going to see Jenny I
really running as a as an assistant as a
support to various roles in the
organization whether it's the data team
or it's a customer services
representative in the call center
and so as Jenny I really evolves to take
that role and help make us as humans
more productive I'm really excited to
also see what we as humans can do with
that extra bandwidth that we get from
from Jenny I taking on some of those
laborious tasks
so I think there's a huge shift coming
in the way that humans and and AI
interact and that AI is really going to
allow us to free up our Diaries it's
today where we're spending all of this
time doing data engineering data
wrangling if you're um spending lots of
times doing document processing manually
if an AI can help you be more efficient
and more productive
then the potential of you as a human and
what you do and get involved with is is
open to many possibilities and that's
what makes me excited for it
yes and thanks for it and and certainly
we'll be seeing lots of lots of
productivity gains and we are all
started you know using this one way or
another in our lives as well but
everyone is also talking around what
will happen to my role you know I'm a
data professional I'm an AI professional
this is this kind of my last question as
well here what advice would you like to
give to individuals and businesses
looking to prepare for a future in as
you said which you know particularly is
going to play a more significant role
what advice would you like to give it to
them
so I am absolutely not worried about AI
taking over all the data jobs because
here's the thing I have been now working
with
um various customers organizations in in
our world looking at their digital
transformation Journeys and actually
what we have seen over time is those
digital transformation Journeys have
stalled because the number of use cases
the impact of digital transformation
across many different business functions
on your entire business model is so big
and radical that just humans working
harder a task is not going to allow us
to digitally transform so in fact we
need the AI and the large language
models we need the new innovation that
allows us to unlock that next level of
disruption Innovation and allows us to
truly digitally transform as
organizations so I see is humans working
smarter not harder
so I do think rules will evolve and
adjust but I think in this new world
it's it's going to be again humans being
involved in higher level tasks in
different kind of job roles versus what
what we're doing today
yes and I at all agree with you in fact
this is also supported by research that
comes in from the numerous you know
economic uh journals as well I've read
one recently which focuses on the U.S
economy and arguing that effectively
what we'll see with jnai will be similar
to what we have seen with the personal
computers when they came you know people
didn't lose their jobs but the economy
was uplifted in time because all exactly
as you said with the productivity gains
that we all got thank you thank you very
much indeed for joining us today Yasmine
it has been in incredibly insightful to
hear your thoughts on the impact and
effective user Ai and the challenges uh
that lie ahead in terms of data
governance in particular as well we look
forward to seeing how AI will continue
to shape the world around us and hope
our viewers will be inspired to embrace
its potential and opportunities thank
you very much indeed thank you for that
foreign